[Musica]
bella tutti ragazzi e beh non ci credo e
ci sono riuscito e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono va dj ed oggi siamo già
steso 1014 conca ragazzina che stiamo
aggiungendo per diventa alla fine delle
canzoni just dance quasi ballate tutte
per questo episodio del sito la prima di
ballard e una che non c'è che mi avete
richieste in tantissimi ma non c'è ma mi
sono arrangiato lo stesso la vedrete con
camino episodio più che rialzi dire
iniziare facendo le prime due come al
solito maicon blog slice vivamente
ragazzi come canzone la conosco
pochissimo ma la faccio perché non avete
richiesto tutti e mi scelgo tizio più
fico
anzi sono sono esattamente uguale la
juve lo dico prima di iniziare punto
alle 5 stelle e stavolta le prendo si
accettano scommesse su quanto schifo
riuscirò a fare mai così fantastico
ragazzino attimo la partenza del genere
ha sognato di parla per secoli
vai così
io ci ho preso gusto
beh a me ragazzi massa canzone di
bellocchi esageratamente spendo cioè non
[Musica]
guardare mai così a madonna ma palco c'è
sculaccione detto non farmi che cazzo
presa bene
vagava non fatevi troppe domande
[Musica]
ma non li vuole
una di una gallina che tenta dico pare
che cosa spesso spero sia un uomo aiuto
ragazzi che stimo sono vivo che mi avete
abbandonato una stella fantastico ho
detto che doveva arrivare a una perfetto
quindi ci ho azzeccato in pieno sta
scaldando per l'ultima ragazzi perché
sarà un delirio veit l'ho visto lei
dedicata e così voglio fare la faccia
del sexy stavolta è quello serio guarda
mostrato sono un panda vai con lady gaga
vai gaga perché la cosa fantastica
poi così cieli monroy di ok è aperto
tutto no non ho cazzo è continua così è
una canzone tutta così ragazzi se andate
al cesso e uguale c'è poi un malore è
l'elettroshock
l'aspetto è la madonna che questo è un
fallo
cazzo parte ragazze mi sembrava
un esame d'ammissione per un manicomio
[Musica]
poi ti fai da te
io ferma donna che chiaro vai piano io
mio
i ragazzi mi sta salendo la lasagna
futuro e 4 cazzo te continua l'europa
[Musica]
la donna è questa canzone
mario giro
[Musica]
basta basta ferma donna ferma sono già
faccio piu sono morto basta oggi ragazzi
scusatemi se tarotto così ma dovevo
conservare le energie per l'ultimo ballo
ragazzi allora tutto quello che avete
visto fino adesso su just dance non era
niente tenetevi pronti per water fabi 6
[Musica]
colgo su jack cosmi ha così mouse
costringe gamma cosco
[Musica]
lo segua etico
come finito quattro ragazzi sono
distrutto mio dio
no
qua
[Musica]
io
rega poter movimentare le lasagne essere
pronti
[Musica]
ovvero vorrebbe frivolo ma che cazzo
stanno facendo
mi capita una nicchia
[Musica]
ma ti paghiamo a caso non vedo
ridatemi ragazzi stato è stata la cosa
impressionante
vogliamo riprovare solo quel coso
d'andata straiato se riesco tipo così
[Musica]
non ci riesco ci ho provato un sono alte
l'importante è provarci ma non ci riesco
va bè ragazzi concluso il primo episodio
prima di farmi seriamente male ma sono
ragazzi splendido è piaciuto lanciato il
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come non i video trovate la
descrizione senso è prescritto
iscrivetevi e ci rivediamo in un
prossimo video ragazzi